for months since the repeal of net
neutrality I've been talking about this
Senate effort to basically undo the
repeal of net neutrality or in other
words it's sort of a Senate bill to
reinstate net neutrality and I've said
so many times that net neutrality
internet freedom we also talked about it
this is one of those meta issues that
when we talk about whatever political
issue is important to you it's sort of
controlled by or it depends on things
like campaign finance and the economic
system that we have and net neutrality
that's a big part of what we're talking
about and the Senate was able to pass
this bill 52 to 47 meaning that every
Democrat in the Senate plus Republican
Susan Collins who we knew had said she
was going to vote for it Republican John
Kennedy and yes much to Pat's the light
Alaska's Lisa Murkowski a Republican all
three of them joining Democrats in
passing this bill to return to Obama era
net neutrality laws here's the big
exciting moment from the Senate the yeas
are 52 the nays are 47 the joint
resolution is passed Wow nothing more
exciting than an announcement of who
voted how in the Senate except the
problem is now it goes to the house
where it's probably going to die so what
do we do next do we just forget about it
and move on I say no I think you know
number one Lobby your members of
Congress get information about how to do
it most effectively a battle for the
Netcom they've been following the net
neutrality issue for a very very long
time and the reason I think it makes
sense to go through the process lobby
your members of Congress have the house
vote is because even if it fails to pass
the House which it probably will it's
going to put all members of the house on
record as either being for net
neutrality as being against net
neutrality or for some of them probably
is not caring enough about it to even
cast a ballot cast the ballot on it and
that could be useful in November right
for voting out these anti net neutrality
clowns and of course if by some unusual
circumstance the House passed it it
would go to trump
and yeah in all likelihood Trump would
veto it since it was his FCC Chairman
Ajit Pi who catalyzed getting rid of net
neutrality to begin with but you know
what with Trump you kind of never know
right if someone says to Trump two
minutes before it gets to his desk
hey what about signing this and going
through with the reinstatement of net
neutrality even though it'd be totally
incoherent with the policy that he's
espoused he might in some kind of
confused stupor just say sure I'll sign
this thing if the right person gets to
him so I don't think that it's a waste
of time I think there is value here but
if you told me that that you want me to
assess the chance of this becoming the
law reinstating that neutrality it's not
very likely and that's really where I
think the focus should be there should
be consequences for elected officials
who oppose net neutrality Chuck Grassley
for example Republican from Iowa get
this guy the hell out of here and use
the fact that he's opposed to net
neutrality to do it John Thune whoever
right get these people out and this is
when it's important to remember
Democrats and Republicans are not the
same it's a losing argument to say these
are the two establishment parties and it
doesn't make any difference who you vote
for
Democrats and Republicans are very
similar on very important major issues
most importantly I would say they're
almost 100% complicit in perpetuating
the existence of the broken campaign
finance system that got them into office
in the first place and why wouldn't they
that's how they gained power but this is
not like a pet issue net neutrality it's
not a niche concern Republicans and
Democrats are worlds apart on this in
the Senate every Democrat voted to
reinstate net neutrality only three
Republicans did so to play the game of
man politicians are all the same they're
all corrupt and it doesn't matter who
you vote for so I'll stay home or vote
for some third party candidate who I
agree with on some things but it's a
whack job in general that's a losing
argument and it's really important for
us to understand
that on really important issues there's
no similarity at all between Democrats
and Republicans
okay devil's advocate this seems like
it's gonna be more of a statement vote
has very little chance of passing as you
laid out could we draw a comparison to
when Republicans tried to repeal
Obamacare 61 times knowing that the
president at the time was not going to
repeal his signature piece of
legislation no wasted all this time and
money and effort we can't we can't draw
an analogy to that because number one
the Obamacare was public in a way the
entire debate around Obamacare and the
controversy around it was public in a
way that is very very different from net
neutrality and on Obamacare you had
people who were proactively opposed to
it there's a very small contingent of
people voters that are actually against
net neutrality it's more indifference
and just sort of like let them do what
they want the I think that there's very
little that's analogous between the two
or are you I would also argue that
there's a big difference between one
vote and 61 votes that's also true
that's also true why is it that it's so
much of an uphill battle on this right
why why is it even a fight for Internet
freedom why is the default that the
corporations and ISPs get their way and
the people get screwed sort of as a
matter of regular doing business it's
part of the problem with the system we
have it's an ugly system it's a hideous
and immoral system and yeah it'll most
likely be an effort that dies in the
house but it's an important issue it's
too important not to fight and that's
why I'm encouraging you to go to battle
for the Netcom get informed Lobby or
members of Congress the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership